good morning everyone
we'll make a start welcome to Baby
District council's planning committee
um
I will now ask the government's officer
to read that domestic arrangements and
and fire regulation
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you're attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure your mobile phones are on silent
or switched off and that your laptop is
also switched to silent be using the
e-voting for this meeting on the modern
gov app so please could members make
sure they are logged in and ready to use
the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except whether
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting
you'll be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker you are also
consenting to be recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
which is Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
you want to enter the atrium if you were
in the atrium at the time of the alarm
follow the signs to the nearest fire
exit use the stairs not the lifts and do
not re-enter the building until told is
safe to do so thank you chair
good morning asking is the chief
planning officer we have Stephen Stroud
the area planning manager Mark Russell
our legal advisor Ian Dupree and a
moment we have present case officers Joe
Hobbs
and and Daniel Cameron
Claire is our governance officer Ward
members present our cancer arthi and I
believe
councilor maybe you are here okay okay
thank you
can I move on to the agenda
thank you very much do you have any
policies for absence
the chair we have apologies from
councilor Islam Holt and counselor as is
substituting and apologies from
councilor Peter beer and councilor maybe
we'll be substituting thank you thank
you
do we see
if if I may Mr chairman could I please
um have noted that I will not be sitting
on the planning committee for the first
item which is for children but I will
then join the planning committee for the
rest of the agenda thank you
thank you do we noted
to receive declarations for pecuni
interests and other registered and
non-registered interests by members I
need to declare councilor Osborne
uh thank you Mr chairman I'd like to um
have a other registerable interest on
dc20
stroke 01094
and I'd like to exercise the right under
Suffolk code of conduct to speak for
three minutes and then leave the meeting
yes yes I think that's that's acceptable
if if there is um sorry counselor are
you going to Osborne are you minded to
speak as a supporter of the application
I haven't seen the I haven't seen the
uh
the presentation but I
I'll make my mind up whether I wish to
speak or Leave the Room
okay I thought well that's all right for
the time being I think
well
counselor if you're saying you have
another Regional interest that normally
means you ought not to yeah
as a speaker if
I said as a public governor on the west
Suffolk Hospital
well I think on this on this item we
have the governance officer correctly if
I'm wrong if I've misunderstood we have
a parish County Parish Council speaking
we as we've heard we have all members we
have at least one possibly two objectors
I believe
so that really unless that Lee only
leaves the possibility of a supporter
speaking
right
yes
under that Mr chairman I I'll leave the
room uh before the uh items it comes up
well I'll listen to the presentation
then leave the room thank you
any other
cancer Barrett normally if that's the
situation
the fact that the counselor is in the
room there's normally debarred by the
fact that he's in the room
so if he says he ought to really leave
the room before if he's well yes
but not even listened to it I think the
presentation okay no I don't think you
should listen to the presentations yeah
I think that's if we're following the
rules do you think Ian yes I agree yeah
thank you any more Council Jameson
um is this relating to the builders and
application DC
2102405 I just want to you know that I
actually lived in bilderston
um I live at the other end of the
village but I just thought I'd better
make you aware
thank you
thank you very much
anymore
nope okay
move on
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 16th of November
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these moons
no
in that case can I have a proposal to
accept them please Council Jameson
a second to please cancel the barrier
thank you
come suffolks officer will now conduct
the electronic votes
thank you chair members that vote
is now in progress
councilor Mabry can I take your vote
please
abstain thank you
councilor Osborne can I take your vote
verbally please four thank you
sorry that's uh ten votes four and one
extension thank you thank you that's
Carrie
to receive notification petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme not received Chad thank you
site inspections do we have any requests
for site inspections
yes chair uh we have one request Harry
Goodrich will be presenting thank you
Aaron would you like to make a
presentation to the committee please
thank you chair and good morning members
so this site is land north of the street
in shotley under the reference of
dc2201562
so the site obviously there is outlined
in red uh with the blue line also
showing land under the ownership of the
applicant
the green parcel there obviously the
large field in the middle of the screen
that is the site itself there's a bus
stop just off to the uh the south of the
site with a pace garage petrograph as
well
so this is a it's a full application for
48 dwellings with 24 affordable units
this is the layout we have currently for
the proposal with a wildflower Meadow to
the north and public open space in the
light green part of land towards the
south of the site
and these are just some sight pictures
that were taken when I conducted a site
visit myself
and this is obviously on the road
looking towards the east towards the
pace garage
west from the junction on the other side
of the road with the site there being on
the left-hand side of the screen
the site itself just sort of is an open
parcel of land it's great to
agricultural land currently
jump forward one just off to the that's
looking to the east
of the site
further to the east along the Hedgerow
which partially to be removed
then off to the west and the housing off
to the West there
and further the housing and that's
thank you chair
Joe clarification about why the council
wanted the site visit
yeah apology so Council Derek Davis who
is with us today has requested a site
visit for this site
uh due to its nature within the parish
and the contentious nature of it
thank you Harry any questions counselor
Byron
um could you uh elaborate on the
contentious nature
yeah uh we've got a number of objections
from member of the parish and I think
Council Davis might be able to help me
here but I believe we have a a number of
objections and generally it's
quite contentious in the village itself
I just wondered how many houses was it
and what was the um the Quantum of
affordable housing no it's 48 dwellings
with 24 affordable so 50 affordable
thank you
any more questions
councilman I mean
the purpose of site visit is if the site
is tricky to view
by looking at what we saw it looks to me
like it's pretty straightforward
um in terms of its layout position and
obviously it's a field which is there
um so I I can't really see that there's
much benefit to gain from a site visit
when it's that type of development
if it's a tricky site which you can't
access or see I think yes there's Merit
to having a site visit but I think with
just looking at what we've been seeing
um I'm not sure merits a visit
from the planning committee
thank you any other comments councilman
crawl is councilor Dave is able to speak
on this
yes
you find a spare microphone
yeah um thank you Harry for for those
beaches the main issue for me is I think
counselors would benefit from seeing
this on this safety aspect
um it's on a a extremely
dangerous Bend there's been a number of
accidents there and I think the access
is an issue and also the speed limit
changes from 40 to 30 and I think it
would be beneficial to councilors to
actually walk the ground so they can see
for themselves
um the contentious issues yeah that will
be dealt with
um in in the planning committee no doubt
but I think certainly the
the important thing is for you to
the access to see the road to see the
highways and judge for yourselves
what you think about that because it is
a dangerous part of the road there I
think that would be beneficial and also
on top of that and you can see it's
quite a large area but I think you would
benefit as well from seeing how the
layout would fit into
area
I'm happy to take questions
have we had a highways report yet
we have got highways comments back I
don't have them to hand but I think
that's relevant to bear in mind
councilor Davis's request
which is based on highways problems not
anything else
I'm starting to get them in at the
market we got them available to give the
reference against Harry I'll have a
quick look
I mean if the highway is suggesting this
is dangerous then
then it has Merit if they're not they're
not see we need to think about that
McCall isn't that more appropriate to
the actual planning application being
heard in committee rather than
um in call for a site visit I just think
it might be premature
thank you
oh
does that help you it's the difference
between the red and the greens are the
red trees that are coming out or trees
that are going in yeah the red trees are
the ones to be removed
along the frontage
I have now got the highways comments to
hand if that would help as well yeah so
we have currently have a holding
objection from the highways Authority
due to the uh cumulative traffic impact
a pedestrian and cycle connectivity
and the site layout
so we have a number of concerns there
from the highways Authority
thank you you're lit up come on
sorry thank you thank you
okay
cancel him
thank you Mr chairman
um this is a an application uh
a
[Music]
um
full application or a
it is a full application full
application yes so the layout would be
fixed yeah and the access onto the site
could be fixed
oh is it one way or the other
thanks to the baron uh yeah I mean I can
see that there's obviously Merit in
having a site inspection but I'm not
quite sure without the facts in front of
us and of looking at where we are
whether it is it is necessary to traips
over to shopping
um to do that so I I would propose that
we we probably can get sufficient from
the uh information normally in the
presentation from the officer
councilor Barrett can I have a second
there
sorry could we have clarifications about
what extra information the case officer
can provide just just for the next one
can I just yeah
was that a proposal to have Society
inspection or to not have the site
inspection
not to have a signing description it
looks like I'm struggling with a
secondary anyway so I'm I'm not really
that worried if you don't want to track
this over to shopping
I'm happy to say if you'd like to say
inspection would have a site inspection
thank you there you go
oh was it do we have a second before
that
councilman Crow
thank you
electronic growth is it
the government's officer will now carry
out your electronic
vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress the council I was born four
thank you councilor Mayberry
I'm going to abstain
thank you members Chad that's
10 votes for sorry nine votes for one
against and one abstention thank you
thank you very much
signed visit will happen in January
subject I do object to the the term
trait over to shot sorry I object to the
term traits over to Charlie's it implies
that the journey to Shockley is not a
pleasant one
um but I don't confirm from Sudbury
isn't excuse me gentlemen that's not a
planning subject to discuss at this
stage thank you
how much moving on
schedule
schedule for planning applications we
will start with dc20
1 sorry 1094 land to the north side of
churchfield road Chilton industrial
estate Chilton Sudbury Suffolk
thank you can I confirm councilor Mabry
you were speaking as a ward member I am
Mr chairman thank you
sorry
Council Osborne has just left the
meeting to record that
I will now invite the case officer Joe
Hobbs to introduce the application to
the committee Joe thank you
being presented to members today is an
outline application for 166 dwellings
and Care home of up to 60 bedrooms in
churchfield Road at churchfield Road
Atlanta the north Churchill Road Chilton
industrial estate
so in the location of Chilton there next
to Sudbury
so here we have the site location just
to give some context to notice you know
the area we have Sudbury Community
Health Center here Churchville
industrial estate
I'll come on to the wider context so we
have Sudbury the application site there
children Justice estate and Chilton
Woods Chilton Woods development just to
share that context there
so the application site just to run
through some of the planning constraints
of the site it's located there you can
see the built up area boundary in brown
and so it's located outside of the
current development plan
boundary
there's also a designation on the site
for the site to be employment land under
amo2 of the baber local plan that just
shows that area there in pink
to go through the other constraints in
the site we have a listed building
listed buildings and a registered Park
and garden around the site so we have
the grade one St Mary's Church down
there's the south east of the site
great to you star Chilton Hall the
garden walls which are grade two listed
and Historic Park and garden just
showing the extent around there
and we'll come on to photos of the other
listed buildings but just show a photo
of children Hall from its North Side
just as we don't have photos later in
the presentation
other constraints to show the public
rights of way around the site so just
showing probably right away which ones
alongside the site here
and then just stepping back a bit The
Wider public rights away networks around
the site
I'm just going to run through some
photographs to the site now the members
did do a site visit in March but not all
members were able to attend but also
just to refresh members memories so the
photo locations that are shown in the
bottom corner here so we're on
churchfield road looking towards the
health center
and then we're looking South towards the
site where um solar Park was recently
granted permission for the employment
unit just uh to the south of the site
there
and just working back around the uh
Health Center
and here we are looking across the site
uh towards children Hall in the
background there
towards the east
now these houses are just the other side
of the health center
showing them but on the east side of
waldenfield road which is the road that
runs alongside this side of the site
here
and that's wardenfield very just saying
existing vegetation that's alongside
that site there
so looking around the site now as you
can see we're looking over over the site
to some of the trees and shrubs and
bushes that are on the site
as we work around the site
and they're looking towards the church
which you can see across the site to the
east there and some of the employment
units disappearing on that side of the
slide
so here we are looking down with uh
towards the south of the site so looking
back towards the health center which is
just behind these uh trees here
and looking across where there is a tree
belt across the north of the site here
we'll get some more photos of those
trees in a second so now we're in a
footpath which runs through the site uh
it's not an official public right-of-way
which you can see it's a well-trodden
path and just showing some of the trees
that have been planted
in that tree belt there
just showing the this looks towards the
south of the site so you can see
um you can see the light through the
trees obviously it's not really leaves
on these trees but you can see that the
uh there are glimpses through the
photographs don't always do it justice
unfortunately on a tiny screen but as
members will recall from slightly do you
get glimpses through
um this tree belt here
when you're standing on that path
I'm just showing a few more pictures of
the trees
doing the planting this is looking
towards that top corner of Chilton Hall
so you can see the Hedge there of
Chilton Hall
and trees within the garden of Chilton
Hall
and then we're just working our way
around the footpath to the east of the
site you'll see there are two foot pass
there is a informal path within the site
and the official public right-of-way
it's right alongside the site there
so we're now back to churchfield Road in
this bottom corner
I just point out this is the location of
one of the accesses I'll show those in a
second on the proposals but here we have
the existing clone units in the church
which is just located
to that side of the slide so my mouse is
Frozen
and this shows uh the sites our
application site is here one of the
accesses is supposed to be here
and existing employment units there
and they were on the side from that
corner just looking across
and although the photos don't do it
justice the land does rise oh you're on
a low past the site here and the Landers
rise As you move into that center of the
site there
and here we are just looking from the
outside the site towards the church just
totally slightly view of the church
there
so under the proposals like I said the
application is outlined there's an
indicative plan and parameter plans
submitted to the application but this
just shows the location of the proposals
so first the vehicle accesses are shown
in red there's two particular accesses
proposed and then there's also a
pedestrian connections to the site which
is sewn in dark blue there
sorry I jumped over there we go
the parameter plan that's the uh the
extent of development set by the outline
application this shows um the accesses
proposed care home would be set in that
location there so it's a 60 bed care
home
and up to 166 residential dwellings
shown in the brown area around here
and this open space ecology mitigation
areas I'll show you a slide in a little
bit more detail of what they propose in
a second
so these show this shows a little bit
more about the ecology mitigation this
was a subject of quite a bit discussion
the application there is priority
grassland on the site which is quite
important in ecological terms it's shown
in yellow so it's broadly constrained to
the outside areas of the site and the
proposals do disturb some of the
priority grass and and so it was agreed
with our ecologists that that could be
translocated and that's shown in that
brown area there and that wouldn't lead
to any harm
today's protected habitats they could
successfully be in effect dug up and
relocated to that location there
other ecology mitigation includes area
in blue which should be managed
specifically for reptiles
and Great Crested Newt Pond and then the
areas in green are the public open space
for the application site
and the areas in blue here show the
surface water feature on the site which
would be
um a Swale a surface water Lagoon to
hold water and so the site could drain
at Greenfield the existing Green Field
run off rate the infiltration was
changed we poor on the site but with
these lagoons it was considered that the
surface water attenuation and Disposal
would be acceptable
so just going on to the other parameter
plans submitting the application uh
Building height parameter plan has been
shown here the darker brown as proposed
to be up to three stories 12.8 meters
high and the lighter brown is up to two
stories so 10.1 meters and that's reach
height so I'm creating the heights up
there so the idea is to have the greater
height towards this area of the site
where there is the two-story Medical
Center
and also density parameter plan has been
submitted to showing the density of up
to 40 dwellings over 40 grams per
hectare
um in this location in dark brown first
40 and then slightly lower density uh in
that location as you're looking towards
the relationship with the Heritage
assets which I'll come on to in a moment
so that's the last parameter plan to
bring it all together and then the
applicants have shown that pink cone
there which is the visibility and their
view of the church when you're when
you're only at the site the views that
would be retained and obviously not
blocked by development
to run through also all other matters
have been considered and mitigation
identified that in terms of Highways is
pointing out this mitigation that have
secured to the Chilton Woods application
which would provide the highways
mitigation required to make this
development acceptable in high-risk
terms at these Junctions
um and so um to
come to the Crux of this application the
key issues as I've run through all the
other issues and the application ecology
surface water we found
um solutions for all those matters
um but we have issues as you'll see from
the recommendation with the principle of
the development and Heritage
so the application site is outside the
development boundary so we have
conflicts with CS2 of the core strategy
and also we have conflicts with
employment it's currently employment
land a designation employment land under
the core strategy and so its loss would
need to be considered under em-24 and
they'd need to meet the tests of that
policy
um
in terms of
important to probably say the location
of this site it is in the board scale of
the district this is a potentially more
accessible site on the edge of Sudbury
Sudbury is at the higher end at the top
of our settlement hierarchy and so there
are potential connections to stable
transport connections to a market town
which is a positive but
notwithstanding its location there are
conflicts with the development plan
which is what we need to base our
planning decision on
um in terms of the conflicts with
employment there are two tests within
the policy em24 that an applicant would
need to meet either of those tests to
justify the loss of employment Land one
is a sustained marketing strategies
demonstrate that there is no kind of
demand and no potential uptake for that
uh that site and that use and the second
one is to demonstrate that the
application that the use of employment
on that site would be inherently
unsuitable
um as you'll see from the detailed
consideration in our report where we did
also seek external advice on that very
matter
um OS has considered that that neither
of those tests are met there wasn't a
sustained marketing campaign and we
considered that it's not been
demonstrated double negative here it's
not been demonstrated the site is
unsuitable inherently unsuitable for
employment so we have no reason to
believe that
one of the other key issues is Heritage
harm I'm just going to run through how
to time quickly on this slide here so
hopefully that will
help paint the picture of where we are
in Heritage Farm so we have a variety of
Heritage armors set out under the mppf
where we have no harm up to
um
substantial harm and this section here
is less than substantial harm
now
the Heritage assets there's been much
detailed consideration by different
parties in this application a number of
different bodies have submitted their
opinions on Heritage on obviously as has
the applicants and also we have made
assessments ourselves
two key areas of Heritage harm in
officers opinion that we need to be
aware of and that is the group of
buildings that form
chosen Hall and the garden rules we
consider that we're at the upper end of
less than substantial harm to the
Heritage assets the significance of the
Heritage assets there and in terms of
the church we consider it's approaching
nearing substantial harm so we're right
near the top end of this less than
substantial harm here
and the reason for that is that the uh
originally the hall and the church was
set in very rural settings and obviously
Sudbury has slowly encroached upon that
setting with the development of the
employment area particularly with the
church and it's considered that the
further development of this site even
with the proposals that were modified
during the course of the application the
proposals were pulled back from Chilton
Hall schemers reduced to 190 dwellings
266 dwellings even with that reduction
it still felt that there's an erosion of
the setting of The Hall which does harm
the significance to a fair degree really
when you were talking about the upper
end of less than substantial harm
it's a matter of obviously existing
development looking at the site the
relationship of the land
to the Heritage assets it's not
necessarily always about whether you can
see the Heritage assets from uh the
application site it's the uh the
significance directed by the historic
setting and in this instance we feel
that it's we consider that it's
um eroding that significance further
as I said just to add that we don't
consider it is substantial harm
um but as I said church is at the higher
end of less than substantial harm
just to remind everyone where those
Heritage assets are
so the um
the recommendation is set out in the
table papers it has been updated since
the committee report was published that
is because we did have a further
representation from our own
environmental health officer just
raising that since the application was
previously considered the standby energy
generation facility has been allowed at
appeal and the impact of that facility
on air quality in terms of the sensitive
receptors in this site would need to be
considered and so at the moment we have
insufficient information to kind of
advise that air quality will be
acceptable so it has formed an
additional reason for refusal which is
shown in bold on the table papers
um Also the table papers raise uh more
uh representations from different
parties
um the officers considered that the
report does cover
all of the representations made there is
one from the applicants as to uh
consider where a proposal was made to
amend the application to be 100
affordable housing so the proposal is
for a market and housing with 35
affordable housing that's what has been
submitted and consulted upon but earlier
this week the applicants proposed that
the scheme is moved to 100 affordable
housing however we reconsider that as a
material change to the proposal that
would require public consultation and a
reconsideration of the planning balance
and so at this time officers can't
advise that members place any weight on
that proposal that Amendment and it's
something that would require further
detailed consideration to see how that
would affect the planning balance
so the application is recommended for
refusal as shown on the tabled papers
and
the reasons for refusal are set out in
there thank you chair
thank you Joe
any questions for the officer
councilor Osborne
Hinton sorry
I know it doesn't
I thought I was suffering from
schizophrenia not just the cold there
um
two questions really based if you could
put up slide 42
whereabouts is the Nestle Pet Food plant
that's
potentially gonna cause a bit of a nib
I don't have
duplication
um it's one of the larger units down
here within the industrial site I don't
know the exact location that that was
considered during the course of the
application the mitigation if I can
provide some more information on that if
that's another question I have is what
on Earth is a nitrate vulnerable
vulnerable Zone
um nitrate vulnerable Zone that's an
area that um
where it's identified that groundwater
can get into aquifers for drinking water
so um it's an area identified by
potentially defra
um and to basically identify that if
nitrates were to enter the ground there
it's likely they would get into the
aquifer so it's a designation set by
central government but it's just
something we need to be aware of and
just making sure that any surface water
discharge that we have from applications
make sure that they are treated the
water's treated so we don't end up
polluting off aquifers
the last last point was German if I may
um the southeast side when we went out
to the site visit was I think popularly
referred to as the HGB toilet
um there are some trees along there as
well others proposing to be kept if so
is that still going to become a hgv
toilet
the Landscaping would be retained except
for the access one of the accesses
vehicle accesses would be proposed in
that location
um I I can't comment on the hdb toilet
situation unfortunately I don't I can't
predict what happens there but some of
the Landscaping is being retained around
the access
thanks for James
thank you Jeff
we've all the other developments going
on in the area is there a proven need
for more houses in children
or on this at this part of Sudbury
land Supply position obviously and we
have a sufficient land Supply
um in baber uh seven and a half years so
uh obviously that play comes into play
in our recommendation in terms of local
housing need that matter specifically
isn't required on this site as it is
with some sites in baber so when we have
sites in the age of Hinterland Villages
our policies cs11 in particular requires
us to demonstrate is there a local
housing need as this is on the edge of a
market town There's no requirement to
actually demonstrate a local housing
need but the point stands that we do
have a healthy land Supply within the
district indicating that there's less
weight placed on the benefit of housing
coming forwards in this site
you are next
thank you chair
Joe thank you for that
um
as the one of the applicants is a health
um organization and a public health
organized
Public Health Organization
um
I think anybody reading the
presentation
would be wondering what the correlation
was between the applicant and what is on
the site so I just want to clarify
the relationship with the health center
or with the care home
as far as the applicant's concerned
thank you
so one of the applicants says NHS
Foundation trust for the right term West
Suffolk they own land behind the
existing Health Center and that's why
they're featuring the application as
they're operating their land there so
they don't own the land where the
proposed care home if that would be a
separate operator separate facility to
them
future
thanks and Crow you
yes thanks Jeffrey
complex application
um there's quite a lot of back and forth
about the allocation
the land for this site
um as employment land as it's currently
designated and the arguments seem to
flow with that evidence being presented
back and forth as I say
um about viability
as I understand I just want to establish
exactly what the policy position is on
this because reference is made to the
emerging joint local plan
um but of course we're basing this on
the current employment
allocation whether or not that lasts
there's no is there when when's the
earliest that any
potential change to the allocation for
this land could be made
in other words what are we actually
looking at right now in terms of the
land allocation
so for the purpose of making a decision
on this application today we must look
at the current development plan and any
other material considerations the
current development plan is as I as I
set out with all the slides and material
considerations can include emerging
local plans but it's the degree to the
advanced stage they're at as to whether
we can place significant weight on it
now we are in examination with our local
plan and there are a number of
objections to different policies and
when there are objections the mppf makes
it clear that we can't place weight on
until they are resolved by an
inspector's report basically coming down
on one side or the other of which uh
which one we should proceed with so at
present we are we're advising that it's
not the proposals in the joint local
plan aren't determinative to determine
this application today we are basing it
on the policies in our current
development plan that's why we're
placing more weight
the reason I ask this if I might share
is that excuse my voice uh is that as I
understand it we can't get an actual
final definitive allocation until the
inspection process has been completed
likely in 2024 and we also can't
determine what purpose that allocation
will be made for and on that basis I'm
just just trying to work this out in my
head because there's a lot of stuff to
cover in the papers
um
the whole question of the viability for
different uses seems completely
irrelevant since we can't tell whether
which which use is likely to take place
is
situation
um yes so with the um marketing campaign
that the applicants need to demonstrate
we would ask for uh reasonable uses to
be proposed and ask for those to be
demonstrated and the same with the
viable form so what we have done is
modeled particular different employment
uses to see whether they would come
forward because you can't say
definitively which employment use could
come forward but there is a range of
potential uses so they've been modeled
with our Consultants who advised us on
this matter further
I think I've got that basically I'm just
trying to work out if that the entire
question is rather moot as far as
viability goes
any more questions
counselor Busby
hi Joe could you go to slide 42 again
for us please
so the church
is
where they're they
that part there
so the problem I have with this is that
we've designated that area as an
employment Zone
how would putting houses on that site be
more damaging to the church
than an impossibly employment
and how did we allow those other in
employment units those industrial units
plus a
that energy generation site so close to
the church I mean it
it seems like we've got one rule for
some things and a different
interpretation for another
yes the um Heritage Farm is
the Heritage time needs to be considered
we have a duty under the planning
application to consider the Heritage
harm now and I think it is fair to say
that recent case law over the summer
which was alluded to in the report has
clarified the level of harm which when
you're approaching substantial harm so I
think without commenting on the decision
to allocate this land previously for
employment we can only make the
assessment now based on current guidance
legislation guidance and case law and
our advice now is that the development
appraisals as shown here would lead to
that level of harm ultimately each
proposal would need to be considered on
its merits if a proposal is coming
forwards for employment we wouldn't have
the conflict with the development plan
in terms of loss of employment it would
be a different planning balance we'd
still take Heritage arm with the utmost
importance but it would be a different
planning balance than we have in this
instance here with the proposals for
housing
okay there's in the same vein if we're
worried about nitrates filtering through
to the aquifer
from housing
well
why wouldn't we be concerned about them
filtering through from an employment
site I would have thought there was more
Danger from that than there is from
residential
um again when we come to the detailed
design of any development we've made
sure that there isn't pollution we would
be able to ensure there are designs in a
surface water disposal to capture
pollution so
any proposal for either employment or
housing would be able to address that
point to an acceptable degree
sounds like we've got the designation of
that site wrong and it probably should
be left as as Parkland
thank you for comment Council advisory
any more questions for the officer
no thank you very much Joe
all right
we have confirmed that councilor Mabry
staying speaking as a ward member we'll
now move on to the parish council
representative Christine Hagan
you have three minutes to adjust the
council
it's wholly in the Parish of Chilton
this Parish Council strongly supports
the conclusions of the officer's report
and the recommendation of refusal of
permission for the reason set out
therein
there's considerable opposition to this
application and we ask you to take
account of the objections from Sudbury
Town Council Greg waldingfield Parish
Council three of your counselors
all of the statutory Heritage and civil
consulties object on grounds of harm to
Heritage you have Mr Lewis's review of
The Heritage evidence and his
conclusions as to the considerable harm
that would be caused by the development
Suffolk Wildlife trust object on
ecological grounds 41 of the 42 public
comments or objectors
the parish council's objections are set
out in our previous letters but in
summary
um they are that this site is allowed is
allocated for employment use not
residential contrary to policy em24
the applicant has failed to show that
the site is inherently unsuitable or not
viable for employment use
there's a cluster of nationally
important Heritage assets within our
Parish
suitable levels of harm to Heritage that
have been identified and not outweighed
by the public benefits of this
development further there's no clear and
convincing justification for this
development
your Authority has a five-year housing
land supply of 6.86 years and the
surplus of 786 units
this application fails to comply with
policies cno6
cn14 and cs-15
the application without a justifiable
need proposes development in the
countryside resulting in landscape harm
as substantiated in the reports of
Pharma and Elwood
policy cs1 requires sustainable
development which this is not
development is contrary to your
development plan and National planning
policies
there are no material considerations
that justify departure from those
policies because the harm identified
substantially and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
accordingly National policies and law
direct the permission should be refused
in addition to the points we've made
previously Chilton Parish Council ask
you to resolve the recommendation of
refusal of this application for the
reasons set out therein
thank you
thank you
any questions for the parish council
no thank you very much
moving on we have
two objectors General Osborne of our
heart you have three minutes between you
and I'll leave it up to you too
time yourselves
can I invite whoever's going first to
start
the allocation of affordable housing
however I strongly feel that this
application needs to be refused as per
the officer's recommendation I will not
waste my one and a half minutes
explaining policies as these are defined
in the report the recently revised homes
and housing strategy clearly states that
the council must build the right homes
in the right place at the right time and
this site is certainly not the right
place
the old prologue site is a strategic
employment allocation which is located
directly adjacent to the largest
industrial area within Sudbury and
offers excellent connectivity with
existing businesses
and has the relevant infrastructure in
place I understand that no robust
marketing has been undertaken on this
even if there had been no take up to
date we need to retain employment sites
such as this so we have suitable land
available as and when required
in respect to the land at the back of
the health center when it was built it
was originally designed as a three-story
building so that it could accommodate
additional needs coming forward however
planning was resubmitted for a two-story
building on the understanding that the
land at the back would be
Town expands and the population grows
two good reasons for refusing this
application members and many more
referred to on page 79 in the office's
recommendation many thanks
good morning I object to this
application for the reasons recorded I
support your officers recommendation of
refusal and permission I live at Chilton
Hall I regard myself as a temporary
custodian of three of these nationally
important Heritage assets for the future
they need your protection now from
irreversible harm that this development
will cause you'll be aware of your legal
Duty which the officers referred to
under the listed building acts to give a
special regard that is great weight to
desirability of preserving these assets
already substantial new housing being
built in children for example
1280 units at Chilton woods and Children
Place
there's no clear or convincing
justification for this development and
the public benefits do not outweigh the
considerable harm to Heritage that this
will cause
further this development doesn't
occurred as the officers told you with
your development plan nor does it Accord
with the nppf policies therefore
permission should be refused
I am I ask you please to adopt the
recommendation and refuse permission I'm
happy to answer questions thank you
thank you
thank you very much
any questions for the objectives
no in that case thank you very much
moving on
we do not have any support as present so
I'll now ask the agent to speak
Jamie Dempster I believe
you have three minutes to address
and chair and fellow committee members
my name is Jamie Dempster and I'm an
associate director at Rock Planning
representing the applicant who would
firstly like to address the refusal
recommendation as it understood that all
matters were resolved when no
substantive noise issues were confirmed
this was the last known outstanding
matter stated by officers in February
2022 and followed much work since the
original submission in March 2020
including substantial revisions in
February 2021 to respond cooperatively
to all officer requests moving however
to the two reasons for refusal we can
discredit the position taken by officers
citing breach of Heritage and employment
policy in so far that no comment has
been received on Heritage since the 4th
of May 2021 when bdc's own Heritage and
design officer concluded that the level
of impact of the indicative layout would
result in a low to medium level of less
than substantial harm
the fact that a critical report by Mr
Lewis was instructed in October 22 and
completed in the same month undermines
the Integrity of this report which in
any event has been flawed by our own
experts response on the level of harm
that the proposed scheme may have on the
noted Heritage assets which was
initially no harm
however if a lower level of harm is
accepted the substantial public benefit
clearly tips in favor of the proposals
and has been reinforced by a hundred
percent affordable housing offer which
provides 36 affordable rent with rents
capped at below local lha levels and 64
shared ownership homes in addition a 60
bed care home which will provide 55
full-time equivalent jobs
yeah we're speaking about 100 offer
which we put forward as an addendum
going
on the item as presented by the officer
thank you okay
in any event in combination with the
public open space
biodiversity and public realm
enhancements which are provided
alongside the 35 offer
these provide a package of significant
public benefits which weigh in our
opinion convincingly in favor of the
proposals
in relation to employment policy to
ensure a robust approach a leading local
agent Fenn Wright was instructed to
advise on this they provided
overwhelming evidence in 2020 and 2021
that commercial development on the site
was unviable and this demonstrated that
the evidence used by Deep bdc's expert
DLP and rlb was flawed therefore
demonstrating the non-viability of
commercial development and compliance
under limited of policy em24 this is now
only worsened by the economic realities
of a projected deep recession by the
bank of England Rising interest rates
softening investment yields and a lack
of occupier confidence in any event the
emerging local plan is seeking to
deallocate employment use from this site
which is a material consideration
in summary The Proposal can provide
affordable housing with whom the
commercial terms are a greed of legal
General and they're here with us today
if you wish to ask many questions
we've demonstrated at the very least a
low to medium level of less than
substantial harm against which the
strength of public benefits weighs in
favor of the proposals and we've
demonstrated a non-viability of
commercial development on site as Joe
explained in her presentation the scheme
is also supported for various technical
reasons such as highways drainage Trees
and Landscaping
your time as well okay thank you
are there any questions for the agent
Council advisory
just making a
an employment site on violent doesn't it
make a residential site unviable as well
sorry my name is Guy Marsden I'm the
agent for the uh applicant
we have legal in general here with us
today with whom terms are agreed for the
development of the site for 100
affordable homes
um and uh in our opinion uh the tenure
of those homes is not a planning
consideration despite the comments which
have been made by the case officer
thank you for your contribution but yet
again you're discussing the subject
we're not discussing today
thank you any more questions
councilman
thank you chair good morning Mr dunster
um I'm trying to get my head around this
care home sort of proposal
but looking in some of the papers I
think there's a debate whether it's that
or something similar can you can he
clarify before I ask the second question
can he clarify for me that the care home
is part of is definitely part of this
proposal
sorry if I can answer that question as
well please
um the care home was introduced
following the public consultation that
we had when a need for a care home was
clearly identified so despite the
um unattractiveness act from a
commercial viability point of view we
provided a care home and we have a
committed interest to acquire that that
site and so in summary we have a
committed party to take forward the
development of the care home and the
residential components of the site
I hope that answers your question thank
you I
can go on to my
second so Care Homes
well regulated and they're usually well
regulated before you even get to the
actual planning stage can I ask if
there's been any discussion with the
Care Quality commission around the
sighting of this care home thank you
we are dealing with a very reputable
care home operator who has got a
substantive presence in the UK market
so although we haven't not had those
dialogue directly with the uh with The
Regulators
they certainly would have done because
they've made this a hard offer for the
opportunity on the site
thank you
can I just come back on that oh yeah
sure yeah okay
um yes well I think probably uh from my
experience the Care Quality commission
are an important element in anything
that is planned around care be that a
nursing or a residential home thank you
any more questions for the agent
if not thank you very much
I'm now going to invite the Suffolk
County Council division member Council
of Faircloth mutton to speak you'll have
five minutes to address the committee on
massive relations to County
thank you Mr chairman uh I appear before
you all today as the division
representative for Sudbury Eastern
welding field the site of the
application in the Parish of Chilton
Falls within my said division
I wish to support the proposals for
rejection by Chilton Parish Council
great waldenfield Parish Council and
Sudbury Town Council all of which are
constituent parishes and town councils
within my division
the reasons that they provide
per the guidance of Claire Philpot to
frame my recommended recommended reasons
for refusal and these Beyond County
issues on the environmental fronts The
Authority that I serve in March 2019
declared a climate emergency
by Great Crested newts lizards and wild
birds this has been highlighted by the
Suffolk Wildlife trust who in turn has
recommended on the basis of the national
planning policy framework of 2021 that
this application be refused on that
basis
as a local division representative I
understand the issues that have been
faced on churchfield road by hgv parking
there have been no proposals in this
application to address such issues I
can't imagine what's an increased flow
of residential parking would do to that
road
I'm not a regular attendee of this
committee I do not take a pairing before
it lightly hence this being my first in
attendance as my tenure as a counselor
on that strain strength of emphasis that
I call upon you to accept the officer's
recommendation for refusal today thank
you
thank you very much
are there any questions
for the County Council
if not thank you very much
moving on
we now have the ward members
um
we have two we have councilor arthi and
councilor Mabry
which one of you is going to make a
start
counselor Rafi you have five minutes to
address the committee okay thank you
very much chairman
um firstly I wanted to thank Joe Hogs
um for all of the work she's put into
this um
occasion
um an excellent report I thought and an
excellent presentation as well this
morning
and also thank her for her detailed
responses to the question we're asked of
her
furthermore we've had well-presented
representations from the parish council
from councilor Osborne Valerie Hart and
Philip mutton
I have to say that I'm in full agreement
with the amended recommendations that
you've got in your table papers this
morning
particularly draw your attention to
little one
the application is contrary to our
policies CS2 and em24 and little two
which addresses Heritage concerns and
identifies the proposals as being
policies CNO 6 cn14 and cs15 and the
nppf
um also just to remind you that the harm
to Heritage assets
um as Joe Hobbs explained is identified
as high in some regards verging on
substantial and just remind you that
substantial is as high as it gets
um and um is the description that would
be attached to the tribal demolition of
a listed building
one last thing to say as a result of
some of the discussion
um this morning there was reference made
to the gas powered generator that was
allowed near the church just to remind
you that you actually refused that
application it was allowed on appeal and
the inspector had to exercise a judgment
of balance in exactly the same way that
you did a committee but he identified
the need for that power generator
outweighed the impact on the Heritage
asset in that case the church here of
course we've got Chilton Hall and its
Gardens as a Heritage asset as well so
just to conclude chairman um I would
very much encourage you to follow the
recommendations in your paper and once
again thank you to Joe Hobbs for her
report
thank you Council rathi councilor Mabry
are you ready to address us you have
five minutes
thank you very much Mr
message comments over the last two years
on this planning application and noted
my objections to it without Reinventing
the wheel I add to it
I fully support The Stance taken by
Charlton Parish Council and Lady heart
of Chilton against the planning
application alongside Greg waldingfield
in Sudbury our County councilor and
others
societies designated Economic
Development land and should be reserved
for such as poets listing
I am currently engaged with a business
that requires land for development but
cannot find any around Sudbury as the
designated land is not being put forward
for either sale or development for that
specific purpose
it has also not been demonstrated by the
applicants that marketing has been
undertaken to achieve a commercial land
sale because I actually have a customer
for some of it
part of the land is NHS designated land
and in consideration of the last of the
vast development
within both children itself and
surrounding villages
we will require and we will need further
medical facilities this land should be
protected as per the Naylor report and I
would like the planning committee to
challenge any possible planning
deviation from this restriction
I note comments about a care home being
built on this site and I will currently
state that the Care Homes within in and
around Sudbury are not as I have recent
experience of them
the site is adjacent to the memorial
lands of children Hall
Chilton Hall is the last remaining
minorial building from the surrounding
area I have stated before the loss of
all Memorial buildings that break
Wallingford little worldingfield Acton
and Sudbury itself
our primary function should be to
protect this memorial building with
Vigor in consideration of Winston
Churchill's quotation which I proceed in
this quote we need to know where we come
from to understand where we are going
how can we measure our district success
if we lose all our protected historical
properties what will we say to our
future Generations if we are the
generation that has lost the last
Memorial property situation around
Sudbury
I currently mourn the loss of all
Memorial buildings and land I have
mentioned above
the site is currently a non-designated
wildlife and Recreation Area for many
leaving aside the merits of whether the
public should enter the site it
nevertheless has become a recreational
relaxation area for the expanding
population of Chilton Sudbury and its
surrounding areas perhaps the call
should be for a compulsory purchase
order for a designated and much needed
Recreation Wildlife Area for the benefit
of the district as councilor Busby
stated this morning it should have been
left as Parkland
cumulative impact of successive planning
applications and has and will have
serious impact on all facilities within
the Sudbury area the committee should
have due regard to these issues as
previously raised by me with planning
offices way back as 2019 during Parish
liaison meetings in Lebanon
including the highway commutative impact
the site at the old Airfield causes the
xgv site causes impactful issues with
traffic particularly when two are
passing in opposite directions on the B
triple one five any further traffic from
any further residential buildings will
cause a huge bottleneck it's already
been commented about The Unofficial hgv
car park on the churchfield
varied particularly with a lack of
toilet facilities this all adds up to
comment further on the recommendation
that the officer has for refusal I urge
my colleagues on the planning committee
to support the offices very good
presentation that this should be refused
thank you
thank you Council Mabry any questions
for the ward members
nope
open the subject for debate who would
like to kick off
counselor Jameson
[Music]
I took a lot of reading
um listening to the thing this morning
when there's with no Market marketing
strategy by the applicant for this site
as an employment site
we've been outside the settlement
boundary and already been designated as
employment land
by our policies
I can't see
how we could approve this at that in as
into that the Heritage issues and the
everything's medium
to lessen substantial harm is quite a
serious implications on the Heritage
assets
so I can't see President Erica I could
support any the application we have in
front of us
but also was mentioned by councilman
councilor Busby I mean should anything
be on this I mean if this is refused
um
with the Heritage issues that are
evident I mean employment is surely
going to be refused as well and has been
stated by both members and perhaps this
should be left as Parkland in the future
thank you Council Jameson
councilman crawl
thank you chair I have to say I'm very
impressed with the the length and number
of reports that have had to be produced
to go along with this application I
think we all probably spent quite a lot
of time in the last two days
particularly in the updated last minute
papers
um another 250 I note I did go through
them and we have employment we have
reports on behalf of Bangor District
Council which we wouldn't normally have
to discuss issues that had been raised
by the applicant and we've looked at
employment we have looked at the
viability we've looked at
um various different models to show that
in fact yes you could do this as
employment land as policy directs we've
looked at noise Acoustics and notably um
from um other representations we've had
from the community on Heritage assets
and the and there's just nothing that
says that you should go against the
officer recommendation here it's um
an overwhelming range of evidence that
backs up the officer's report I think
it's a shame that the officers had to go
to all this trouble of getting all these
um these reviews done but we have
independent external
reports that back up our offices and I
think under those circumstances we can
do no more than back the recommendation
so I should be clearly voting for any uh
any refusal on this application
I'm prepared to propose that we refuse
the application as per the officer
recommendation
um including the um amendments in the
tabled papers we received yesterday uh
so that is um
points one two three four in bold five
and
um and then part two so I would I would
propose that recommendation
thank you counselor
cancer as your second
thank you
is there any more comments councilor
McLaren thank you chair as I
a great
concern of this care home in this
application
um we've heard that there's possibly not
a need locally
but
[Music]
um
I believe are in where Care Homes are
cited is important
um
most mostly for the patients or the
residents that will be accommodated
there
and this seems they're bordering on an
industrial site
if we think about Healthcare being total
and complete there doesn't look much
options for these residents to
extend their
activity or anything outside of that
region so for me that is a big
problem with this application and I will
be supporting the officer's
recommendation
against the baron yeah um I I'm
conflicted by this application on the
basis that
um with its history as I know uh when
the applicant was trying to build
a employment land or employment use on
the site that was turned down
um
and now we're in the situation so it's
gone to employ to a residential and it
looks like it's going to be turned down
um
you know this is becoming a site that's
being planted blight
because I think we need to be careful I
mean the the Heritage uh is
causing a major issue
so uh obviously we can only look at what
we've got in front of us on the basis of
that we are constrained by policy had
the applicant had a
um
marketing program for is it 24 months
um and that marketing program had been
exhausted and there's no viable
actually came forward or use
I think we'd be in a situation where we
would then be able to
Grant residential but clearly that's not
the case
so I'm not against Residential
unfortunately I think we are constrained
by the policies that we have in front of
us and we can't really go against those
policies because they're very
straightforward
but it does leave the site again in a
position where it will be left empty for
another God knows how many years
so uh reluctantly I find myself
um going down the route of accepting the
officer recommendation but with the
caveat that
um
presumably if employment
options come forward
then those employment options would have
more public benefit to outweigh the less
than substantial Heritage harm I'm
looking at Joe to see if that's
something that where we would end up
but that's where we're in a difficult
position here and we obviously don't
you know it's not possible with some of
my colleagues who think it should go
back to being a it's never it's actually
never been in Parkland it's been a field
so I think we need to be realistic about
where we are with this
thank you
any more comments come to those people
yeah thank you chair first of all I have
to say that I resent receiving 250 pages
of additional papers 24 hours or two
days before a planning committee
especially since the majority of those
papers have been around in existence for
two years 18 months 12 months are
already on our existing website
and I would refuse to read them in
future
I think any table papers should be new
evidence new information not repeat of
stuff that's already been circulated to
us I'm sorry but my time is more
valuable than to repeat
reading of 250 pages
having said that
I also find that
Heritage we need to sort Heritage out
how on Earth can an inspector
allow a gas
power plant to be within yards of a
grade one listed Church
and say that's fine because oh well
there's some public benefit yeah of
course there is
and not allow housing two or three
hundred meters away I mean just Beggars
believe quite frankly and it implies
from According to if we have adopt the
rules according to that inspector
providing the public benefits
there is a public benefit it doesn't
matter what it is we can swamp the
church I mean either it's a grade one
listed church that needs
protecting or it doesn't
I just think we Heritage is is
ridiculous the way that we treat it
especially in this case
um and I think we just need to
sort that out because it has such an
impact
on almost all of the applications that
we receive because we have a
sick amount of Heritage in this District
it's crazed in one one week we throw
something out because
there's a grade two listed building
within half a mile of it
and then next week we allow something
built over the top of the church
because the so-called public benefit I
mean I just don't understand that
um
in this case I still think
the uh the officer's recommendations on
balance are the right ones
[Music]
thank you
anyone else want to make a comment
right
I mean it establish exactly what we're
going to vote on
so can you help me
I guess chance in accordance with the
amendment recommendation on the table
papers I mean that's what the council
and the crore was proposing and you're
happy with that as a secondary
thank you that is the proposal that's on
the table I will now ask the governance
officer
to take a vote
thank you
thank you chairman does that vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that's nine votes for
refusal of the application thank you
thank you very much
we will now
take a break
or
10 minutes probably back here at 11
o'clock three
back everyone
um
we're not going to move to the third
item on the agenda 6C
dc2106
9977-182 beerus Road great cornard
um
counts about Houston is one of the
committee Oregon
thank you
I may have missed something what's
happened to 6B
will explain that in a moment thank you
thank you
I'd also add that the officer has to do
some baby care so we have to get her in
free thank you
I will now ask Elizabeth flood to
present the application to the committee
thank you
thank you so this is the third matters
uh for 46 uh dwellings
um to the rear of 182 a bjores road in
great cornard
um the outline for this application
included access layout and scale and
therefore only appearance and
Landscaping are to be considered so it's
a bit different to the normal
um
the normal ones
where we look at more details that
Reserve matters so this is at the site
this is Beers Road uh with Sudbury Town
Center to the to the top
uh this is the railway line
uh you can see the site here and the
dwelling at the front here is to be
demolished
uh so the site is are pretty clear
there's some buildings that the at the
rear here as well that are to be
demolished
again site location plan so you can see
the existing dwelling along bjores road
that will be demolished and the two
garages there's also a
electricity pylon across the site which
will be undergrounded and you can see
the railway on the edge of the site here
and the edge of the house is there and
this building here is the annex to 180
of yours Road
again
um it's outside the built-up area
boundary but the principle of
development's already been approved
under the outline and it's on the edge
but outside of the flood risk area
do that there on the boundary
so there were no constraints on this
site
layout
the layout has previously been approved
and then there was a non-material
Amendment for some some tweaks to the
layout but it's basically as was
approved at outline
um you can see the the house is
demolished in a new a new dwelling on
bjores road and then the access road
along here the area of open space and to
retain trees and the suds the affordable
housing will be in this location at the
back here
and again this layout has already been
approved and then the dwellings will
come off the spine Road along here
again these are the proposed house types
so so the pink
and red colors are the affordables and
then the others you can see there's
quite a mix of different house types
within it
uh these Street Scenes so this is at the
top
so you can see
these um it's sort of a mixture of
Suffolk vernacular uh design various
different designs
again this is looking along the spine
Road
see
various different designs again these
are the market dwellings there's two
Bungalows here as part of the proposals
uh these are Street Scenes further up so
this is the the block of uh affordable
um housing Flats so these are six one
bed and three two bed dwellings
and again these are two more of the
affordable dwellings so as you can see
they're a similar design to some of the
market dwellings again the
the type of housing in terms of the
blocks and so on have already been
approved so it's just the appearance
that we're considering today
again these are Street Scenes further
into the site
and this is yours Rose so this is
existing this is 182 which is to be
demolished and then this is the proposal
so this is the access as it is now and
then what will we replace will be a
dwelling here
slightly closer to the neighbor but
still with a gap and then the access
will come to the other side of the
dwelling along here
and you can see sort of pale other the
dwellings at the back the new houses
with the with the housing on bjores road
at the front
foreign
block for the affordable housing it's
been designed so at the front it does
look like sort of three separate
dwellings it's quite a bulky building
um but we've done our best in terms of
design to make it look as if it's um
different houses
again these are the flats
this is
um the flat over garage
at the back there's another affordable
this would be a two bed sort of detached
again let's see elevations again this is
another of the affordables this is
um these will be four two beds
and that's the final affordable
dwellings these would be two free beds
uh and then this is just um some of the
market dwellings there are going to be
two Market Flats so these are the flats
there's a one two bed and one one bed
and then these are some of the larger
dwellings
again they will quite quite different
but all the things that suffered
vernacular
these are the Bungalows so the two two
Bungalows that's been proposed and this
is
um an example of the play area so there
will be a small play area in this as
part of the public open space and what
they're proposing is sort of natural
wooden type Play features but it's
proposed that that all the details of
which will be conditioned
and this is the landscape plan sorry
it's not very easy to see but the
Landscaping mainly will be the public
open space area here and then the trees
on the boundary will be retained and
then they'll be at some small trees
added but it's quite a dense site so
there isn't a space for a lot of
additional Landscaping
again phasing so they're going to start
with phase one two three and four so the
affordables will be done in first phase
and these are the site plans so that's
the existing access between the two
dwellings
that's 182a which is to be demolished
and that's the neighbor
again you can see them a bit further
away
is this the rear of 182a so this will be
where the access comes through
this is looking towards the railway this
is the site with the railway at the rear
again this is looking across the site
that's the annex at 180 so these are the
two windows that we've looked to retain
protect in terms of giving them some
Outlook
again this is looking across the site to
the end
so you can see that most of the
Landscaping is on the
um on the boundaries these are the
buildings that will be demolished
again these are the trees that have been
to be retained as part of the open space
and that's the annex at 180.
and that's it and so the recommendation
is a set out in your report to approve
subject to the the conditions proposed
thank you
thank you Elizabeth
ah
Council Rowan
that's logging off there
um yeah um I was looking at what the
Paris was saying in between what stops
what is stopping children running across
the um Railway line
we're proposing to
we're proposing to have a condition on
Boundary treatment so we can ensure that
there is a significant fence along that
boundary
councilman Avery
thank you Mr chairman I've got one or
two questions
um the first again is is about the play
area is that going to be fenced off
please from the entrance Road that's the
first question
again the con the details of the play
area are to be agreed but I think in
this case we probably will ask for
fencing given that it is close to the uh
the access
right
um thank you I would suggest that that
is necessary
um
another question because these
properties are going to be fairly close
to the railway line and that Railway
line although it's only classed as a
branch line is very well used
um is there a plan for triple glazing in
the windows
yes it has been looked at it by
Environmental Protection and they are
comfortable that the acoustic there will
be sufficient acoustic with with triple
glazing
um another question that I have is the
flats that are um basically on the um
on the extension of the flood plain
in consideration
of the wet weather that we have at the
moment thankfully I am still safe and
flooding but I know other properties
within the district now do have flooding
um are these Flats going to be put on
some sort of stilts or something so
they're raised off the ground please no
as far as I understand they are outside
the flood zone and the layout has
already been approved so we're not we're
not considering where the position of
those flats are that was all previously
approved outline we're just looking at
the appearance of those Flats so we
can't the
um the flood officer has no concerns
about that site about that where those
are cited but like I say we are we can
only look at appearance at this point
not the layout of where those are
so in my book appearance does taking
into account whether a house is put on
Stoops or not but there we go
um and lastly you're talking about
protecting the annex
the wind the over the overlooking of
that Annex
um how is that going to be achieved can
you just confirm it please thank you so
it's a bit difficult because we need to
be allowed they need to have Outlook but
also have privacy so what we have
um asked the what we're proposing is the
boundary treatment will ensure that
there is no boundary treatment along
where they there are two windows one's
obscurely glaze because it's their
bathroom and ones that
um not not obscurely Grays and what
we're proposing is
um at the bottom of that window to have
spiky plants so that the occupiers of
the surrounding dwellings don't go too
close to that window but also ensure
that there is no boundary treatment on
that so they still get an Outlook
um thank you I would recommend pyrie
cancer works wonders thank you
any more questions for the officer
Angela
just to confirm because I can't see in
the papers but the uh the original
planning application was refused and
went through on a few is that right
um I don't believe so I think Mark can
confirm because he was the case officer
but I believe it was approved it wasn't
appeal
our outline which was granted 2018
um
there may have been a previous case I'm
not aware of the chair to be honest with
we can check for that no I'm not worried
it's just I I seem to there's quite a
lot of history of this one so
uh right that's fine
any more questions Angela both be well
I think what we've been asked to look at
is so minor in terms of the the site
that I've proposed that we accept the uh
officers recommendations
as much else to discuss we're in
question stage at the moment if you'd
like to come back to the emails and when
we reach the debate stage
I have it
are there any more questions
for the officer
no
in that case thank you very much
Elizabeth
moving on councilor Busby over to you
speak have we got can we still ask
questions
now I'd like to propose that we accept
the officer's recommendations on this
one I think I think
around debating
I was just going to say I thought the
house designs looked actually quite a
nice mix I don't know if anybody else
felt that
yeah yeah
well yeah but actually
yes I just thought no I mean for high
density housing you know it didn't look
half bad
thank you you open you
anymore
if not
we have a proposal
to accept the officer's recommendation
is that correct well
yes it is I wasn't sure whether the
counselor maybe might have offered an
extra condition did I understand that
correctly or not councilor Mayberry that
would be that would be nice Mr Russell
thank you
what was the condition that you um spoke
of
um
[Applause]
Channel
yes my condition would be that the play
area is fenced off
and also that
um
we've agreed to Triple there should be
triple glazing
acoustic glazing but I think
that's already been agreed and and the
last is that um
pirate campuses are planted to protect
the annex because they are evergreen
have lovely berries and would be very
nice
okay I think both of those are already
covered in kind there's Elizabeth
there's a planting condition isn't there
for the last point there or is there a
special condition for the Privacy off is
it already covered by a condition
um at the moment we are asking we're
saying PD removed from fences walls and
hedges along the boundary with 182
bjores road to stop anyone putting a
fence up we're also requiring details of
boundary treatment and details of the
children's play equipment that usually
includes boundary treatment but we can
say including fencing
um the Landscaping plan already shows
those spiky plants but I don't know what
the species is
so we could ask for additional
details about escaping so if I make sure
we could as an advisory officers to
ensure that
um
spiky planting is clarified I don't know
if you can be
prescriptive as saying the exact species
you mentioned counselor but yeah I
thought you'd be those specific yeah
that's as advice to us and the other
point is to advise that the play
equipment
um has a fencing around it is that where
he covered did you say that was already
job it wasn't it
at the moment we've got conditioned to
ask for details of the play equipment so
we could okay expand that so to ensure
that there's a reference to fencing in
that
it needs to be totally
circled with fencing I just think this
is the offense between the play
equipment and the road
it's a small development I don't think
we should actually it's been pregnant on
the road right
I suppose a
second uh do you accept as a moment you
don't have to
yes yes you do thank you
so that's part parts of the proposal
are there any more comments
if not I've asked the government officer
if you're going to doctor electronic
event thank you
on the agenda
councilor Osborne have you managed to
log in or would you like me to take
yours you've done it yeah thank you I
see now
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's carried
thank you everyone thank you Elizabeth
thank you we'll move straight into the
next one which is 6B
um
this is
land
dc2102 405 land east of us is close and
Rotherham Road bilderston
um
we
don't have to remember here but
I were invited
Daniel
Cameron to make a statement to the
committee first
and then we can decide where we're going
next
over to you Daniel thank you chair so
um
we received emails last night from the
owner of the site indicating they've
sold their interest in the site to orbit
homes
orbit homes have changed agents for the
site to their own preferred agent and
have asked that this item be withdrawn
from consideration to allow them to make
their own improvements to the scheme and
to make changes to the house types so
that their preferred house types and
they um we would then effectively
postpone this decision and bring the
scheme back to committee following
um
consultation on new drawings engagement
with the parish council and then come
back to you with an improved scheme
so the first question to members is on
that basis are you content to see this
withdrawn from the agenda so that we
engage with orbit and their agents and
then bring this back in a more fit state
for your consideration at the
appropriate time
thank you Daniel comments from anyone do
you want to just visit
I think bear in mind the information
that we just received I think we made to
make a recommendation that we with the
applications withdrawn and applicant has
an option to bring it back
the committee when they are sufficiently
revised
thank you
secondary thanks for hanging
I did have a question as well and that
is all because of a registered social
landlord
uh only 17 of the
48 are affordable houses does this mean
they're getting into the sort of
development business as well there's
affordable housing but are they going to
come back and say you want to do it all
affordable they they might well they
might well do that so at present
completely different to them so it's so
it's only uh as of last night that they
owned the site so the site had been
brought forward with the original owner
and agent
um 35 was to be delivered as agreed as
part of the outline and secured by the
section 106 on the site
um orbit have since taken ownership they
may wish to revise
the tendency and the arrangement in
terms of affordable housing they might
take it up they might leave it as it is
but at the moment we don't know what
their intentions are we are you know
that they now own the site or would like
to make improvements
Mr chairman I think it's important then
that it does come back to the committee
um because it could be that we've got to
start from square one again it could
robbery yes but but
we'll give the applicant the opportunity
to do that so I have a proposal from
councilor Barrett to accept the
officer's recommendation Council Mabry
yes I would like to Second it that we do
withdraw it thank you
you might have waited till I finish
I'd about to say yes councilman girl you
can just it and notice this is dated
originally from 2015. so it's a long
while it's been going on and the expiry
date is listed as the 28th of January
this year
that's this year not next year so um and
it it would seem is it likely we're
going to get a new outline application
as opposed to just a new set of reserved
matters do we have any indication
well if members wanted to
consider the application before us we
could Grant the reserve matters and then
orbit would be left with an option of
either coming forward with a fresh
application or submitting a section 73
in either case both will come back to
members for I don't think anybody wants
that their consideration
um
yes the the original outline is quite
old there was a significant delay in
agreeing with section 106 to attach to
that outline so I think the original
decision was only issued in 2017. um
that then rolled on and during the
coronavirus pandemic
um government made changes to the manner
in which Reserve matters can come
forward to give additional time to
developers to bring them forward so it
managed to
under that
that provision and then effectively
this has been kept going trying to get
Amendment and and revision
um as one of the first things all we've
done is said that they're happy to
extend the scheme to allow their
revision to come in consultation to
happen and then for us to come back and
present this to members and
it sounds as though it's going to take
consultation whatever doesn't it I I
yeah
thank you
I'm going to ask the governor's officers
to conduct a vote I'll first of all ask
you to please read out what you've just
typed in that box as being the motion
features so the boat reads the
application on the dc21
02405 be withdrawn from the agenda to
enable officers and the applicant to
obtain further information and the
application to return to committee at a
later date
if everybody's happy with that I will
yep thank you that vote is now in
progress
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous
thank you Claire thanks for everyone for
your attendance the next meeting is
penciled in for the 14th of December
but I've had no indication yet of how
many there might be there it's likely
just to be the children heat to HUB
application
all right more Chilton for you okay he's
hub
just don't ask
I've got a surprise
yeah so Jasmine was the case officer
okay okay
thank you very much
so that's the possible possible one
coming to us on the footage okay thank
you very much